c'est une escalade sans fin qui se joue
depuis plusieurs heures entre moscou et
les occidentaux au centre de l'échiquier
l'ukraine craignant une invasion à tout
moment le président américain joe biden
vient de placer 8500 militaires en état
d' alerte prêts à être déployés alors
s'agit-il d'une démonstration de force
ou la menace est elle réelle elle l'est
en tout cas pour les états unis et la
grande bretagne qui ont préféré rappeler
une partie de leur personnel
diplomatique ainsi que leurs familles
présents à kiev
envahir l'ukraine pour les russes va
être une entreprise douloureuse violente
et sanglante
je pense qu'il est très important que
les gens en russie sache que cela
pourrait être une nouvelle tchétchénie
un peu plus tôt c'est l'otan qui a
annoncé mettre ses forces en état de
disponibilité le danemark vient
d'envoyer une frégate en mer baltique et
s'apprête à déployer des chasseurs f-16
moscou par le d'hystérie l'union
européenne qui vient de débloquer une
aide financière d'un recul deux
milliards d'euros appel au calme
faisant ce qu'il faut faire mais en
évitant de d'une crise de nerf
sur le terrain cette tension est devenu
le quotidien des ukrainiens nous sommes
à quelques kilomètres du front à donesk
bastions des séparatistes pro-russes
entre peur et l'institut de la jeunesse
ukrainienne redoutent que le conflit
s'envenime c'est toujours dangereux ici
c'est effrayant parce que pendant toute
mon enfance à donetsk j'ai entendu la
guerre les bombardements les chars
rouler dans la ville je suis déjà
fatigués par cette situation le conflit
n'a pas de sens on ne sait même pas
pourquoi la guerre continue c'est comme
une sorte de conflit qui suit son cours
côté français emmanuel macron veut se
poser en médiateur
il s'entretiendra dans les prochains
jours avec son homologue vladimir
poutine pour proposer un chemin de
désescalade
le projet